morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have
several bills that have been noticed for
today's hearings but before we get into
those I'd like you to please join me in
the Pledge of Allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America
and to the Republic for which it stands
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
thank you everyone
the um the first bill for our
consideration this morning is a Senate
Bill 174 and I'm pleased to welcome my
fellow resident from Londonderry the
senator from district 14 another Sharon
Carson who is the Prime sponsor welcome
senator
thank you Mr chairman and good morning
and good morning to the honorable
members of the House HHS committee I
have this morning for your consideration
Senate Bill 174 relative to Veterans
access to health care for the record my
name is Sharon Carson and I have the
pleasure of representing Senate District
14 comprising the towns of Londonderry
Hudson and Auburn
this bill repeals two unfunded statutes
related to health care and mental health
services for veterans this bill also
instructs the Department of Health and
Human Services and the department of
military Affairs and Veterans Services
to report to the oversight committee on
Health and Human Services regarding
veterans access to health care and
Mental Health Services this bill was
submitted at the request of the
Department's again of Health and Human
Services and Military Affairs and
Veterans Services
Mr Warren Perry as well as Ms Wendy
Altman are here to provide context and
to answer questions that you might have
those departments continue to work
collaborative collaboratively to
leverage all available resources to meet
the needs of New Hampshire's service
members veterans and their families
the close collaboration between DHHS and
dma
dmavs also with the support of the U.S
Department of Veterans Affairs New
Hampshire hospitals and the Community
Mental Health Centers renders the need
for Navigators as intended by these
statutes unnecessary
RSA 126a 81 and 82 do not improve the
current practices that are already
optimizing access to all services for
veterans and that includes health
behavioral health education Financial
employment
Etc
implementing these Provisions will
disrupt the effective practices
currently in use
RSA 126a colon 81 requires the
Department of Health and Human Services
to train and use veteran service
officers employed by dmabs to train
veteran Health Navigators to identify
all federal and other health benefits
coverage and services available to
Veterans and their families this will
adversely impact the service officer's
ability to perform the core mission of
connecting veterans to VA and state
benefits
the requirements of RSA 126a colon 82
are currently being met without the need
for additional resources the division of
community-based military programs in
coordination with DHHS is facilitating
Partnerships with state federal and
Community providers to deliver services
to New Hampshire's veterans service
members and their families this includes
improving Service delivery ensuring cost
efficiency through decreased overlap
improving access navigation and
coordinations of services and support
the provisions of these two statutes
have not been implemented as there has
not been sufficient funding to carry out
their purpose
there is a caveat in the RSA
funding these Provisions will force
implementation which would prove to be
redundant and wasteful funding these
requirements would be throwing funds at
a problem that was solved by the
creation of the Department of military
Affairs and Veterans Services in 2019
and Mr chairman I'm going to conclude my
testimony at this point and I would ask
the committee to save their questions
for the two individuals that I mentioned
one from the Department of Health and
argument services and from D maps that
will be able to answer your questions
much better than I can okay thank you
thank you very much for your time this
morning okay thank you Senator Carson
okay in that same vein as a senator had
indicated we also have Warren Perry the
deputy adjutant General here to testify
good morning Mr chair if it uh if it
pleases the committee I would ask Wendy
Altman to join me so we could jointly
testifying sure that's fine
for the record my name is Warren Perry
I'm the deputy adjunct general for New
Hampshire's Department of military
Affairs and Veterans Services
and good morning my name is Wendy Altman
and I am the bureau chief at the Bureau
of elderly and Adult Services at the
Department of Health and Human Services
so I would just uh thanks the committee
it's uh honor to testify here this
morning I just Echo all of Senator
Carson's uh testimony this morning and
add that uh
in addition to the comments that she
made some of the concrete things that
we're doing to make sure that that the
veterans of the state have access to
care and and uh uh access to all types
of care in those categories that she
mentioned that in the last biennium
there was a 1.5 million dollar
appropriation uh
in hb2 to get after these things
specifically so without The Navigators
right to just to implement some programs
to do that
in that we we have two contracts one
with Easter Seals and one with the
partnership for public health both of
those contracts are focusing on
eliminating uh social isolation and
mental health
issues that are associated with veterans
with with military service those
programs have been implemented are are
and we're making great Headway on on in
both of those program programs
also we've uh instituted uh some
provider focused training uh
specifically to help identify service
members veterans and their families
across the state so that they can get
access to the resources and care that
they would that they have earned through
their veteran service
so there's a 10 a 10 part video series
that we have on our websites that really
focuses on what we call the ask the
question Campaign which is just helping
providers identify if somebody has
served and then being able to provide
culturally competent care for them right
we don't you don't necessarily have had
to serve to provide good care to
Veterans but you do need to understand
them right I use the allegory of people
who are victims of sexual trauma you
don't have to have been the victim of
sexual trauma to be able to provide
competent care but you do need to
understand some of the culture and and
Things That Go On uh in the military so
you can provide that care additionally
we are entering into a marketing
contract that will focus on providers
and helping providers understand what
resources there are available for
veterans so this this requirement there
for to have the veterans service
officers
go outside of what is their trained
Comfort work to provide navigation
through Social Service provision you
know it's just it's not necessary and
would also detract from their ability to
be able to connect veterans with the
benefits the other benefits they've
earned through their service right so
our veteran service officers in the
division of veterans Service uh division
of better Services there are seven of
them uh they bring in about 65 million
dollars a year in benefits to the
veterans of New Hampshire so we don't
want to take away from that we want them
focused on getting them connected to the
benefits and that the the experts in
Social Work continue to be able to
provide those other services good warm
handoffs good good close collaboration
with uh with Wendy and her team at HHS
good close coordination with the
Community Mental Health Centers and
other service providers across the state
and let the veteran service officers
continue to do their work so in some
I'll conclude my my statements by saying
you know this this this
bill that was passed that created the
this this idea of healthcare Navigators
it's it's really unnecessary and I you
know kind of tongue-in-cheek call it a
you know a uh a solution looking for a
problem to solve right so really what we
want to do here today is just clean up
the statutes let us continue to operate
the way we are not create any other
resource burden on the state and
continue to provide great services to
our veterans and I'll let Wendy make a
statement and I'll answer any questions
that you may have
thank you
um I'd like to provide some additional
testimony to align with uh Warren's work
that he does within the department of
military Affairs and Veterans Services
the Bureau of elderly and Adult Services
and others within the department
work in tandem with the staff under the
department of military Affairs and
Affairs and Veterans Services in ways
that serve people who have served in the
military their families and a number of
other requirements that had been
proposed in this legislation as
expressed in the testimony the close
collaboration between our department and
the department of military Affairs and
Veterans Services along with the support
of the U.S Department of Veteran Affairs
New Hampshire's hospitals and Community
Mental Health Centers renders the need
for Navigators as a as intended by these
statutes unnecessary some examples of
the work that we do in coordination and
collaboration with the Department of
Veterans Services
um
is we have currently established
programs and Partnerships to provide
warm handoffs provide joint appointments
for those who have served in the
military who may need supports relative
to caregiver support Medicare counseling
looking at access to other social
services
while they also have questions about
their veterans benefits and questions
that the Department of Veteran Affairs
staff can provide
within our aging and disability Resource
Centers Statewide we offer those joint
appointments we also have agreements
between the White River Junction VA and
the Manchester VA to help with those
individuals who want to self-direct
their home and community-based services
through the VA
and this creates other opportunities to
connect
with the staff who serve under warrant
and his team we also require and provide
ongoing military culture training and
support and coordinate with the ask the
question campaign and marketing there is
also full-time there are also staff
who are located within our community
mental health centers who Focus solely
on helping individuals who have served
in the military and their families who
have cultural competence and we
coordinate and collaborate with them on
an ongoing basis with our programs
within the department and the staff of
the Department of Veteran Affairs
we provide a lot of leadership and
support and we work to continuously
improve and build on those strengths and
expand the work that we do when there
are opportunities and we have ongoing
connections with those staff at the
state level and also at the regional
level within our communities
thank you
my questions from committee members
representative Weber
thank you for being here and thank you
for taking my question I'm wondering if
you're experiencing or what you're
experiencing in the way of delays of
getting services to people we've we've
been hearing a lot about
the concerns brought on by lack of
Health Care Workforce and I'm wondering
if there are delays in getting care for
veterans that might be resultant on that
particularly as you're trying to make
these fairly intricate connections
so I think I think I would answer that
thank you for the question
representative I think that the best way
to answer that is the veteran population
in terms of uh capacity for care is no
different than the population as as at
large so if they're if you're
experiencing issues getting care in the
community you want to see a cardiologist
or you want to see a mental health
professional those carry over I think
probably very very similarly in the
veteran Community as well so everybody
faces that one of the things we're very
careful about is trying not to you're
trying not to create a new system just
for veterans use you know leverage the
existing systems to get after that uh to
get after you know the problems that we
have but in the veteran Community there
are other things that are available to
them that are not available to the to
the community at large so we we have uh
the uh the vet centers there are two vet
centers in the state one up in uh in
Berlin and one in Hooksett that they
have very specific uh constituencies
generally uh PTSD combat related trauma
and military sexual trauma but they
provide another resource that wouldn't
necessarily be available to the public
so in those instances the care you would
access to care would be easier and
faster than it would be
but I you know all in all I think the
best answer I can give you is it's no
different for you know Joe public than
it is for Joe veteran
follow-up sure thank you Mr chair
um is there not a presence in Keene
anymore
there is uh not not the there's prob
there is presence in Keen for uh
veterans service I'm sure community
health centers and some other things
there but in terms of the VA I'm there
may be a community-based out patient
Clinic there wasn't there was a and I
thought the last time I drove by there
there are people behind you nodding
their heads so I mean I just wanted to
be sure that was still there but
specific the vet centers are specific to
mental health PTSD and military sexual
trauma and combat trauma that's why I
mentioned those two okay so it's a
separate it's that's a it's a treatment
area it's yes yes gotcha thank you very
much representative Murphy did you have
your hand up earlier okay representative
Nagel thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question
um just to be polite we have a really
complicated siled fragmented Health Care
system that I don't think serves people
with complex physical mental
disabilities very well
um I don't think I'm
saying anything insightful with that
what I was excited about this is what
we're trying to find in our Health Care
system is individuals that'll help
people with complex disabilities
navigate an incredibly complicated
system
I really thought that this was a good
program to do that and might be an
inspiring way to help our Health Care
system as a whole accomplish that
problem what I'm wondering is you're
telling me that this is not necessary
but what I'm not necessarily hearing is
how is the systems that exist now
helping me isn't veteran with a complex
mental and physical disability to
navigate the complexity of this system
so I
the first thing I want to say is the way
this bill was written is not the answer
so that that's the first thing I'm going
to say it's like well it looks good on
its outset the way that this was going
to be implemented was not going to solve
the problem right it's not going to get
to answer the question that you just
asked I think I think what we're doing
now in partnership with DHHS is not
creating a new system for veterans but
leveraging the system that we have in
the state and making that a an entryway
into those systems as we go one of the
contracts that I that I mentioned that
we have with uh you know based on that
1.5 million dollar funding is with
partnership for public health and in The
Lakes Region the Lakes Region veteran
Coalition has established a network
specific to Veterans to be able to have
them get access to those complex care
all those co-occurring morbidities that
people have you know if they have a PTSD
and now they have substance abuse
associated with that suicidal ideation
but not only that but they're diabetic
and they need to you know they need good
case work to to be able to get after
that the coalitions that the Lakes
Region veteran Coalition is the model by
which one of these contracts is going
out around the state regionally and
creating more and more of these of these
networks so I that's the way to really
get after it right so that's the first
thing the second piece is we have to be
able to tell people what resources are
available to them right so the marketing
piece of this is is it's absolutely
critical right so we're we're we are
about about ready to go to GNC with the
marketing contract and that marketing
contract is going to Target providers
with the resources that might be
available to them it's amazing to me
what people don't know like if like YP
people are on Medicaid when they're
eligible for VA benefits and how how
could we alleviate the stress on the
Medicaid system if we could just get
them into the VA system which already
provides culturally competent care
so those are some of the ways that I
would that would offer to you that that
that's happening but the way this law
was written it takes a person who's
responsible for helping connect a
service-connected medical condition to a
VA benef claim benefit so that you can
get compensation and pen and then turn
them into a social worker and that's
just to my way of thinking that's the
wrong idea so I've answered your
question I think but I've also said you
know the healthcare Navigator is really
not the right way to do it the way it's
written in this in this statute
other questions
see no other questions okay thank you
thank you very much for your time thank
you
also signed up to speak is David Kenney
from svac
sure and we're wondering what sfax
stands for
thank you Mr chairman finally a question
I can answer
um
there we go uh thank you Mr chairman um
svac stands for the state veterans
advisory committee uh we were formed in
uh 2001
um basically we were a follow-on to an
original committee that was in the 90s
that pretty much had the same Mission so
we are comprised right now about 20
veterans service organizations in the
State uh many of you may be familiar
with the American Legion VFW all sit at
our table the the nature of svac quite
frankly is we meet once a month during
the legislative session and our job is
to basically discuss these legislations
and make sure that they're in the right
vein for supporting veterans here in the
state of New Hampshire it also provides
a communication conduit
from the legislature back to these
organizations as well so in in our
discussions during these meetings we
have the ability to take information
that is provided to us by various
organizations uh various entities that
come to the state that want to establish
a new Services here for veterans and
bring that back to the organization so
that we can essentially distribute that
information as widely as possible to all
of the state groups and the state
organizations
to essentially illustrate Warren's
earlier point was to get the information
out and to try to be really really
focused on marketing if you will as much
of that information as possible to
Veterans we have a very diverse
population here in the state we have a
lot of Young Veterans that are very
technology so for them getting
information off the web is very easy but
we also have an aging population in this
state a lot of Vietnam veterans Korean
veterans who not as a Droid on
technology and so for them we have to
reach out to them the more traditional
ways and having that ability to go in
that diverse Direction
hopefully gives us the ability to
connect as much as possible
um as far as the bill here this morning
uh the one Beauty about testifying after
the experts is that they cut through
about three quarters of the things you
were going to say
so I would simply say that we did take
this up with uh the last s back and it
was unanimously voted that we were we
would like to support this bill we do
think that it's a common sense approach
as illustrated by the testimony earlier
and we are confident that by doing so it
will not negate any services
from the veteran Community here in the
state of New Hampshire
um we're in close contact with Warren's
office obviously as well as some of the
other organizations around the state
including the VA
um so we're we're constantly informed
about all the changes that are being
made with Community community-based Care
with the VA and with dmapps and and
truthfully we're we're very satisfied
with the direction that things are going
and uh and we'd certainly like to
continue that so we really appreciate
your listening and I don't open to any
questions thank you thank you
questions from committee members
representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman
can you tell me if
the there's a 10-year mental health plan
which I'm not sure if that pertains to
the kind of services that you're talking
about
but that out of the veterans being
offered any kind of
mental health care or health care that
anybody else is
also
provided for
uh thank you representative for the
question um truthfully that's not my
area of expertise but I can tell you
what I do know
um I can tell you that the VA
specifically does have an offer mental
health care as well as our
community-based services to Warren's
Point earlier the one thing that's the
one aspect of mental health care for the
veteran Community is that there is some
uniqueness to it in the sense that the
veterans are dealing with
mental problems that are not necessarily
part of the general populace and so
having that ability or having that kind
of mental health provider if you will
that understands that culture and
understands those kinds of issues are
crucially important so in addition to
what the VA is providing we're also
reaching out to you know community-based
providers that also understand the
culture and as mentioned earlier the ask
the question campaign is also when
another
prong to that that approach if you will
where providers will be trained or on
the actual military culture so they too
can provide services to the military and
essentially as we as we say we they can
talk the talk they understand the
language and they understand you know
the culture and that's that's the beauty
of it so
um the short answer is is that those are
ever expanding services and I think the
VA and community base right now is
addressing those issues a follow-up
follow-up
is that any different from the kind of
care that police would get or firemen
would get
I would say yes and no I mean as far as
the the trauma that you might address in
those issues absolutely I would say that
the type of care might be similar but I
think when you're looking at police fire
and Military there are three distinct
cultures too even though the trauma that
they experience might be similar but
they're three distinct cultures Warren
Perry may have some comment on that as
well he may be able to illustrate
further
again Warren Perry from partner military
Affairs American Services regarding your
first question representative McKay the
the department of military Affairs and
veteran services was a party to
development of the 10-year mental health
plan so we we had input to that with
regard to uh with regard to the similar
the similarities between paramilitary
organizations police and fire and and
the military the trauma can be the same
just the circumstances are different and
so I I would think that the the mental
health professionals in that regard
would be able to meet those those people
where they are and provide the
appropriate service
thank you
um representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman thank you taking my question
um
as you know in White River there's a
fairly large you know VA Medical Center
um and it in the VA system is really
well connected you know electronically
and otherwise and I'm wondering what if
any is there an impact on the veterans
that are living in New Hampshire that
receive their care in White River or
Boston where we used to refer to a lot
if there's any you know
um uh impact on that ability
I would say that uh you know the
first of all the White River Junction
facility right now is headed up by Dr
Brent Rush
Brett's experience is psychology
so you know mental health is kind of his
his wheelhouse
um and I can tell you that the
facilities at White River Junction have
been a great augment for us here in that
when we need to provide Mental Health
Services that for example we've had
challenges here in the state with with
providing beds right mental health beds
and so in circumstances like that where
we need to get someone into a scenario
where they're in a closed environment
where they can get Direct Care White
River Junction has been at the fore and
being able to do those types of things
and their and they're staffed to handle
those issues could we make improvements
in that area I think so and I think the
the
um the discussion right now and the
public forum certainly indicates that
but I think as far as the VA is
concerned we're addressing those issues
as best we can but I think also
Manchester is looking at at ways in
which they can do that also in addition
to providing the mental health care at
the community level we'd like to try to
address those issues as early as we can
so when a veteran presents themselves
with a particular you know challenge we
try to get them into the appropriate
care as quickly as possible so White
River is really kind of a another tool
in that toolbox if you will and it's an
excellent facility I've been over there
several times and it's it's an awesome
facility thank you thank you
other questions
saying no other questions okay thank you
thank you very much Mr chairman
I have no uh what else signed up to
testify on Senate Bill 174 does anyone
else wish to testify representative
Weber
I was just wondering Mr chairman if this
might not be a bill that is uh of the
sort that we could just go immediately
into executive session I I don't know if
there are other members of the committee
who want I don't want to rush things if
people feel they need to take more time
with it but it seems to me that this one
might be relatively clear and we could
exec it immediately I have no objection
does anyone have any objections to
doing that
okay well why don't we go ahead and do
some point of order um so I'm I'm
assuming uh that we don't have to notice
this separately if we're exacting it
together with the hearing
rule 44 I believe it is C says executive
sessions may also be held without
further notice if held immediately after
the close of a duly noticed public
hearing with the concurrence of the
chair and ranking member perfect okay I
just want to make sure we're doing
everything by the book Thank you
session I'd be glad to make a motion
okay yes let's do that then let's
proceed to an executive session on
Senate Bill 174 representative Weber uh
Mr chair I would move on to pass on
Senate bill 174. I don't think I need to
recap the testimony that was given but
it was unanimous in One Direction and
um it sounds like things are going well
and we shouldn't mess with it so we need
to clean up the things that need to be
cleaned up to allow them to continue to
proceed okay so good any other
discussion
you need a second right yeah okay did I
hear a second that was me okay thank you
representative Nagel uh no other
discussion okay let's uh the clerk is
ready
I would ask him to call the roll
all right
um
a lot of us aren't here but um I'll
start with me
representative King yes representative
Koval yes representative
Missouri
yes representative Nagel
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative
Canon yes
representative
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes
representative
okay and representative McDonald yes
and yeah is one two three
10 11 12 13 14 0.
okay remove consent yes uh without
objection
thank you Mr chairman thank you I was
thank you for that suggestion I will get
you a
thank you
procedural question are our rules any
different than the senates
yes entirely and the reason I ask is all
my bills got exact a minute we did them
well and the Senate does it that way but
I will say that we operate under Mason's
rules of procedure and the Senate
operates under Roberts and then we all
have our own customs and ways of doing
things so uh this is in the nature of a
senate proceeding but it's it's a new
formulation to let us get bills like
this going
thanks okay thank you
okay
um having moved on and
exact uh and heard all testimony for
Senate Bill 174. uh let us now proceed
to Senate bill 30.
um Senator Whitley is the prime sponsor
uh welcome senator
foreign
thank you Mr chair good morning members
of the committee it's good to be back in
the house thank you for welcoming me for
the record my name is Becky Whitley and
I'm honored to serve New Hampshire
Senate District 15 which includes the
wonderful communities of Beau Concord
Penacook and Hopkinton
so today I'm here to introduce Senate
bill 30. this is a housekeeping bill
that was requested by the New Hampshire
Council of Developmental Disabilities
for a little background the council is a
federally funded state agency that
promotes self-determination integration
and inclusion for New Hampshire citizens
with developmental disabilities
so because it is a a sort of federal
state uh combination the council is
required uh has a certain amount of
requirements from the federal government
through federal regulations and through
state government so per federal law the
council is made up of at least 60
percent people with developmental
disabilities or their Guardians so the
purpose of this bill is to update their
state statute their RSA in alignment
with their other Federal requirements
so a little more detail into that the
council is required by federal law to
set aside nine seats for various state
agencies including their Federal
partners
like the institute on disability the
disability rights Center
um as well as the Department of
Education DHHS and other disability
adjacent organizations so the current
wording under the council's membership
terms state that no more than they may
have no more than 21 members so I think
changing the wording to at least 21 will
bring bring them into compliance with
their Federal mandate for membership and
there is a representative from the
council who can expand on that further
so alongside that change the council is
also requesting removal of the language
stating vacancies will be filled for the
expired term because they feel that it
has caused some fill seats vacated
midterm as to when their terms end I'm
happy to take any questions but we'll
defer more technical questions to the
operations of the council and to their
Federal requirements to the staff from
the DD Council behind me so thank you
for your time and I'm happy to take any
questions questions for Senator Whitley
yes representative Weber
thank you and thank you for bringing us
the bill Senator
um
so what if we remove that
one sentence my question becomes
does that mean that when there is a
vacancy somebody simply gets appointed
for a full term starting at at the date
of the week of their appointment
that that's a good question I'm going to
defer that to sort of what happens now
and how they believe that language will
sort of fix that problem if that's okay
thank you ma'am thank you
other questions for Senator Whitley
I see Newton thank you thank you Mr
chair
also signed up to speak is is Adora
Rodriguez Legend from the New Hampshire
Council on developmental disabilities
good morning
good morning Mr chair members of the
committee thank you for hearing me for
the record my name is Isadora Rodriguez
legendre I serve as the executive
director at the New Hampshire Council on
developmental disabilities the DD
council is dedicated to dignity
full rights of citizenship cultural
diversity equal opportunities and full
participation for all New Hampshire
citizens with intellectual and
developmental disabilities
as Senator Whitley stated this is a
housekeeping Bill intended to align our
state statute RSA 19j with our federal
requirements we are required to have
nine separate entities
under that law and so to maintain our 60
percent of individuals and Guardians
with lived experience of Developmental
Disabilities we need to add more seats
than 21 right it's basic math we need
about two-thirds of our members having
lived experience of just developmental
disability so with nine agency seats
that leaves you know about 18 member
seats to be be in compliance so merely
changing
the at the
verbiage to say at least from up to will
help with that in regards to the member
terms so we do have bylaws and our
bylaws have been updated to simplify the
term limits for members who leave
midterm or members who are added to the
council when someone leaves
and how we do that now is members are
seated for three-year terms they are
gubernatorial appointments and so if
someone leaves the council either you
know one year in or two years in before
their term has expired we do identify a
new member to fill that seat and
represent that vacancy and we have that
person
fill the rest of the year we operate on
a federal fiscal year so we have their
official term begin on October 1st to be
consistent with a three-year term under
a federal fiscal year and that has
eliminated a lot of confusion because we
used to have to track exactly which
month someone left and how much was left
in their unexpired term and this really
just is it's so much easier to keep
track of and people know when their
start date is and when their end date is
and then they are eligible to reapply
for a second three-year term
um and that it creates also an easiness
to reapply to the governor's office when
we know that term is expiring around
September
I could go on and on about the DD
Council I'm happy to take any questions
specifically about the legislation
before you
um and if there's anything I haven't
answered please let me know
thank you representative Shapiro thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for coming
again and taking your questions when we
heard a bill earlier about the council
House Bill 238 maybe I'm comparing
apples to oranges here so I'm sure you
can clarify this but
um it was referenced in 171 a33 that 51
percent of the members of the council
shall be people with
um developmental disabilities and now
we're hearing 60 percent so
of those different categories there are
different councils one is the
developmental Services quality Council
which is the one which is the one under
171 a it is a separate Council that is
made up of a lot of stakeholders we have
a c on that Council we also see a person
with a disability a direct support
professional and an enhanced family care
provider to that Council because those
are important voices to have one
considering quality of Services Under
the Department of Health and Human
Services for people with developmental
disabilities but we are a different
Council we operate under the federal act
known as the DD act it's the
developmental disabilities Bill of
Rights and assistance Act
thank you for indulging me educating me
other questions representative Nagle
this is just a quickie um are you going
to be submitting any kind of testimony
with your contact information I I do
have written testimony figure okay in
your contacts oh thanks thank you yeah
you got you did receive it yeah
uh representative thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking my question uh
could could you explain me how it's
happening now so you said that
requirement
to have
at least not more than 21 conflicts with
a requirement
to have at least 60 percent
of certain demographic and then with
Federal
requirement to have at least nine
representatives from certain
organizations so wouldn't Federal
requirement just override any conflict
that exists
uh so to answer your question yes thank
you for that question yes the federal
uh law would Trump the state law in this
particular case however however we feel
that it's important to align these two
so that the state mirrors what the
federal requirement is so that we're not
having to make those decisions and it
makes
sense for the state law to say exactly
how the council should be seated in
order for not to be confusion right
follow what uh follow up
in your
uh
consequences of breaking state law of
breaking these requirements of having
non-representatives in federal law
so
um we are 100 federally funded so there
is a consequence for us not adhering to
the federal law are potentially our
funding could be at risk we have
received this lap on the wrist
um previously when I first started at
the council there were seven agency
seats one individual was holding the
seat for the required
um older Americans act and title V and
Title IX of the Social Security Act
which are maternal and child health and
then um Social Security benefits for
people with disabilities and so their uh
response to that makeup was that you
should really have uh individual
entities that have the expertise to help
inform your decisions and your
priorities that uh know about those
particular areas of those laws that
that's why they named them in the
federal law
as far as
consequences of
not being aligned with the state law we
have more than 21 members now so I
haven't gotten any knocks on my door
saying you can't add more people
because you've reached your limit at the
state level especially when we explain
that the state law is not consistent
with our federal requirement
and it's the voices of the people with
disabilities that should be most present
in our work
other questions uh representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman thank you again
and is it
um
my calculation is that if you had 22.5
people you would be okay with the
math but not with the number of persons
so it am I correct in thinking that we
don't necessarily need to change it to
23 because there may be adjustments down
the road in those other things but if we
just say no less than 21 then the state
and the federal can both be complied
with at the same time and then
presumably your your bylaws which sound
like they're relatively robust at this
point can take care of any adjustments
that need to be made
exactly
we wanted to make it as simple as
possible and instead of changing our
state law to say at least 23 which would
make the math work we just decided to
change the phrase at least
um
it aligns perfectly with the federal
requirements that way okay thank you
other questions
yes representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman I notice you're a
social worker yeah which is fine
that's a at a previous meeting
it was very uh painful to sit here
to feel the tension or stress
between various components that are
dealing with the DD population and have
been for years there have been
long-standing problems
so that I think our Senator is trying to
open up a more positive communication
that seems to be missing at times I was
very startled by the amount of pain that
seemed to be exhibited I don't know if
you had the same experience
yes there is a lot of tension especially
around some of the systems change work
um especially for people with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities in their families because
there's no way for them to know how
that's going to impact their services
and so there's always going to be
concerns about unknowns and that creates
a lot of tension and a lot of kind of
wanting to hang on to how things are
done because at least you know what to
expect right so that's a that's a lot
some of that tension can be whittled
down to that but I I think
we're always going to have differences
as far as systems go that serve large
amounts of people it's never going to be
exactly perfect for every single
individual and and you know we have to
kind of come to terms with that and do
the best we can and that's why the
councils like the quality Council are so
important because they're made up of
stakeholder groups that can kind of
speak to the different issues that
people are experiencing on the ground
so we're just gonna have to continue to
try and meet somewhere in the middle as
best we can
that's my social work answer
okay other questions
representative Merchant thank you Mr
chair
one of the things that has been raised
in the past with some councils in some
boards and commissions
compliance to 91a requires a physical
Quorum and given the fact that many of
your constituents on the council may
have a challenge physically going to a
place
is there any thoughts on trying to
minimize that or what I'm trying to do
is
could we possibly expand it so we have
more opportunity for people to
participate without having to go through
the traveling requirements particularly
during the winter time
yes thank you so much for that question
I I can say it has made it easier for
people to participate virtually
over the last few years we recently
um went from meeting every other month
to meeting quarterly which cuts down on
the number of meetings
um
we took a page out of the governor's
Commission on disability and wrote into
our bylaws that someone who needs an ADA
accommodation for meeting attendance
would be counted as in person as long as
they have a disability
and that's it stated that that's the
reason they cannot attend
um we uh we did pretty well with
attendance at our last meeting a lot of
our agency seats are in the Concord area
which helps a lot
um and then some of our community
members also
um can we are able to reimburse them for
transportation
one of them you know got we got a
um a non-emergency transport for them to
come from the Portsmouth area so we we
make it work as best we can there are
times like in January very it was almost
100 percent virtual attendance because
the weather was bad and there were a lot
of circumstances however
um we're in our minutes for that meeting
we did cite that there continued to be a
federal emergency and that due to
circumstances with transportation that
what we did was just have voice votes
for anything that needed to be voted on
and um
we do the best we can
follow up follow-up and so with this
what I'm hearing will be clear at this
point in time it's not necessary to try
to modify 91a to try to accommodate the
council
I thank you for that follow-up question
I would not say that that's the case I
would say that having this anxiety of
trying to meet in person Quorum when you
have an organization like ours that's
where 60 of our membership is comprised
of individuals with lived experience of
intellectual and developmental
disabilities who don't drive who may not
have access to Transportation whose
family members maybe their only source
of support for the family members they
may be the only person providing support
for that individual at home at any given
time and so they can't just pick up and
come to a meeting in Concord when they
live in Keene it's not ideal and it's
typically not possible so again I think
because of our uh the makeup of our
organization we need to be able to make
consistent accommodations for those
folks that have a really legitimate
reason for not being able to be in
person
could I interject a point of order Mr
chair uh having had the experience in a
previous committee
of having had the clerk tell us that
once we got into 91a areas that were not
included in the original bill it was
going to be a non-germaine Amendment and
we would need to have a whole new
hearing which is not a problem we can do
that
um
I wonder if the answer here might not be
in light of how very controversial those
Provisions are to save those for a
different Bill and to get this taken
care of and perhaps put in a bill next
time to deal with the issue that we now
know is an issue so we could put a bill
in on that
representative do you have a question
regarding representative whoever's
comment or
kind of different
is it of the witness or yeah thank you
and uh thank you for taking my question
thank you for listening to my question
would you believe that if House Bill 308
passes it passed in the house and it's
on to the Senate it would address
no it would cover it would cover all
councils about remote meetings so it
would it would take care of that so I
hope the Senate is listening thank you
nice other questions
seeing no other questions
okay thank you very much thank you
I have no one else signed up to testify
on Senate Bill 30 does anyone else wish
to testify
seeing none I am going to close the
public hearing on Senate Bill 30 and I
am going to open the public hearing on
Senate Bill 35. uh Senate Senator
Rosenwald is the prime sponsor and I
would invite her to come forward
good morning Senator good morning
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record I'm Senator
Cindy Rosenwald from District 13 which
is most of Nashua and I'm pleased to
introduce Senate Bill 35 which
anticipates FDA approval of two vaccines
against RSV this spring I'm not even
going to try to pronounce the full name
um of this virus but this bill adds
these two vaccines to the list of
vaccinations that adults may receive in
pharmacies
as we've read in the news are as few as
the disease that mostly affects children
and has led to an increase in Pediatric
Hospital admissions but is also among
the highest causes of respiratory
illness death in older adults the
vaccine will be approved for adults over
60.
allowing adults to receive vaccines in
pharmacies has been authorized for 15
years in New Hampshire I think I was the
original sponsor it's convenient and
it's less expensive than getting
vaccinated in a doctor's office since
there's no need for a copay or
co-insurance
saving time and money is a good way to
encourage more adults to get recommended
vaccinations this bill has the support
of the Board of Pharmacy and I hope the
committee will look favorably on it
thank you Mr chairman thank you Senator
Senator when you have a chance could you
fill out a pin card for us yes for our
records I'm sorry no that's okay that I
haven't any questions for Senator
Rosenwald
Senator representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman and welcome home
Senator thank you but dear friend uh
yeah well education's kind of taken over
the other end of the hall a permanent
change of the room or just temporary
we're running on double rooms because of
I'm not sure now but anyway I'm sorry
um let me just go back I thought I heard
you say there were two
um additions
so there's the RSV and there is there
another Edition as well no two different
manufacturers oh I'm sorry RSV for
adults
Bill 35 as did the Senate Health and
Human Services committee
um
as Senator Rosenwald indicated in her
testimony it it you know provides
um uh changes the statute to allow for
this uh vaccine to be administered in
the pharmacy community and what we found
during the whole covet experience over
the last few years
well over 50 percent of all of the
coveted vaccines were administered in
community pharmacies
good morning good morning everyone my
name is Albert Rogers I'm the pharmacy
manager at Shaw's Pharmacy in Windham
New Hampshire I think this bill is a
great idea both for to protect patients
and to just improve General Health in
New Hampshire I'm fully in some shots
has been fully supportive this bill and
I hope uh hope it passes
any questions for me any questions
okay I'm seeing none thank you thank you
so much for your time have a wonderful
day thank you too
also signed up to speak is
representative Gary Merchant
from our committee
thank you Mr chairman and for the record
my name is Gary Merchant
proved disposal method was that we
listed every pill and the hospice nurse
and I flushed them and I am so guilty
about all those eight-legged frogs down
in Northfield and South but
this is a much better way
again we worked with Des to make sure
that that kind of stuff doesn't happen
that does a nice controlled method for
disposal that's environmentally safe
representative Shapiro in in the notes
from the Senate hearing there's some
discussion which I don't fully
understand about different types of
medicine
um
liquid medicines but anyway the long and
short of it would be that now all this
has been worked out and that all the
medications that were
going to be unused or were unused would
be able to be put in this lock box and
um
gotten rid of that way correct
correct it creates a proper disposal
method so one of the other committees I
serve on is Jack car and we just went
through a whole discussion about
single-use bags for the drug take back
program that are that are
environmentally safe and contained so if
something were to break open it doesn't
leak
thank you
other questions
representative Murphy
thank you for taking my question um
I don't know how it's disposed of you
know in general but I'm assuming that in
I don't know the statute but are you
aware does it do they have to maintain
the labeling on the medications so that
they the pharmacist knows I mean I don't
think all the drugs are co-mingled is
that correct I don't know the statue
that controls that but I would assume
that they have to be disposed of with
the proper labeling on them is that
correct again I'm outside my area of
expertise maybe somebody else can answer
that of my understanding representative
rich is over there as quickly raising
his hand saying I know the answer so he
can answer your question over there he
wasn't there before so I was trying to
go to you but thank you
representative Merton did you want to
speak on this sir
well in regards to the disposal of the
medications first of all I want to say
thank you senator for bringing this
forth because it is a real problem with
nursing homes
um both the amount of drugs to get
disposed to begin with I'd like to find
a way to reduce it so we don't have to
dispose of it but more importantly back
into the packaging and so forth it
depends upon how it's disposed if you
will by the facility there's different
ways to do it there's not one size fits
all so it could be open to it I do know
from the Board of Pharmacy being on the
before this has been a problem I know we
try to
take the medications that were not
utilized and to redistribute them
through a quote Pharmacy but that didn't
pan out because there wasn't a lot of
support for it but the problem you're
talking about has not gone away
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh sorry I'm new to
this process like can you explain me uh
sobious switch the new agency who will
have this burden and also like I saw
some objection from Department of
Environmental Services as is the ones
who will be paying uh for this new
process
thank you for your questions so the
disposal process is the same the
difference is it's not a one-off so it's
not every time they have drugs they have
to call the pharmacist and dispose of
the drugs they're allowed to
collectively collect the drugs and then
call a pharmacist once so they instead
of having a pharmacist come to their
facility say five or six times in a
month they can come once and dispose of
everything at once as far as a des
concern we did work with Des to craft an
amendment in the Senate that took care
of the Des concerns and she's in the
room she just thanked me for accepting
the amendment that we crafted that meets
their concerns as well
other questions
so you know other questions thank you
also signed up to testify is Rosemary
simoneau from Golden View
did I pronounce your last name correctly
you did perfect thank you Rosemary
Seminole for a golden view Health Care
Center and I think I have the answers to
your questions so far
I brought a demonstration of what we do
now
foreign
so the pills come like this from the
pharmacy it's a month at a time
they are labeled on top here with the
information
and then
um when somebody as you say I'm sorry I
have to interrupt you I've just been
advised there's no props allowed and
during testimony or
I'm sorry
not my not my rule just
the past
is that that way yes okay because I was
just I
we had the Whizzinator
I don't know maybe there's been a change
that I didn't I don't know
we have however been able to see what
she's talking about
thank you thank you for doing that you
know thank you for your intentions and
that's okay
um anyway so it comes in a 30-day card
um we do have Supply limits on things so
we asked the pharmacy to govern it for
us for the delivery so a seven day
supply however depending on how the
provider writes this prescription we we
do have a lot of medication left after
somebody passes away or discharges
because we have a rehab
um so then those pills are collected on
those cards there's a jug of called RX
Destroyer it's a chemical I don't know
what it is
um and then the pills are pushed out of
those cards one by one with a pharmacist
and a nurse
and those pills are put in the base and
the chemical goes in it and then it's
destroyed in August we destroyed 4 000
pills so it's labor intensive for the
pharmacist and the nurse to sit there
literally and and poke them out
um I did go to the Board of Pharmacy uh
to see if we nursing homes could have it
they said no you have to have a change
in the law and that's when I reached out
to the senator here and he was gracious
enough to help us so you know in this
day and age with health care I look for
efficiencies this will cut down on RN
and pharmacist time and it's also safe
because those
um the take back boxes if you're not
familiar with them are double locked the
pharmacist has a key the nurse has a key
and it's those cards are put in in its
totality into that that box you can't
open the box once they're put in and
then they're taken away and incinerated
we cannot put liquids in it though
however that is not allowed at this
point in time but everything else is and
the Board of Pharmacy is supportive of
our efforts here
thank you are you taking questions or
I could try okay any questions yes
representative Nagel
see I didn't until now I have a question
about the lock boxes can each key open
that box individually or do you need
both keys to both keys okay then that
answers my question thank you
representative Weber
you just piqued my interest what what
happens to the liquids
those are destroyed in the process that
we currently have okay thank you
other questions
see no other questions thank you very
much
again thank you for bringing that stuff
in
uh no one else has signed up to testify
on Senate Bill 50. does anyone else wish
to testify
okay seeing no one else I'm going to
close public hearing on Senate bill 50.
um we uh we're doing very well today the
next hearing is not scheduled until 11
30 for on Senate bill 83. so again we
will be in recess for the next 17
minutes
um
what's the pleasure of the committee
I'm I'm recalling that representative
kofalt expressed some reservations about
particularly in light of the fact that
we are very low on Personnel today so
um
I'd be ready to but I want to make sure
that we defer to
everybody's Comfort level quite well
taken
oh yes we'll stand in recess then for
the next 17 minutes and we can be in at
11 30.
the public hearing on Senate Bill 83 and
recognize Senator Apprentice the prime
sponsor
good morning chair McDonald and members
of
house Health and Human Services for the
record my name is suprentice I'm the
state senator from District Five
representing a large part of Grafton
County part of Sullivan County and one
Community lovely New London New
Hampshire in Merrimack County
I'm here before you as was stated to
introduce Senate bill 83. I was actually
asked to sponsor this bill by the New
Hampshire nurse practitioners
Association of which we have
Representatives here today the purpose
here is to help streamline patient care
for patients streamline care for
patients and decreased the cost for
patients by cutting down on the number
of visits to a provider to have a form
signed if this will also cut down on a
duplication of effort within Health Care
practices
Senate Bill 83 will update New Hampshire
law to be congruent with current
practice in New Hampshire currently
outdated laws and institutional culture
have forms that mandate a physician's
signature even though they fall well
within the practice of an advanced
practice registered nurse in aprm New
Hampshire nurse practitioners do have
full autonomy of practice and are
signing many of these forms already
aprns our nurse practitioners were
talking about are an integral part of
New Hampshire's Health Care system and
are growing in numbers
they serve all aspects of care
outpatient care and hospital care
specialty care and have received
additional education in patient
assessment diagnosis and treatment
The Institute of medicine the national
Governors Governors Association and the
Federal Trade Commission among others
all recommend removing practice barriers
for the APRN practice Senate Bill 83
will help us move towards that goal
I am certainly happy to answer any
questions you might have I do have
Representatives again here with me and
they have some more specific examples
but I'm going to just offer one up and I
see Dr Palmer over here and I see Dr
Nagel on the other side if I missed any
other doctors or nurses I am sorry but
when my daughter would go to Camp
Calumet
over in Freedom New Hampshire every
summer she had a camp physical form that
needed to be completed and down the
bottom it would say physician signature
but she would have a nurse practitioner
complete her physical and so what
happened was that the nurse practitioner
who has this is within their scope of
practice they're not signing anything
that isn't within what they can do but
that clearly is so instead of sending me
away and saying you're going to have to
see a different pediatrician or saw a
different pediatric practitioner or
physician or leaving this for me to come
back for or having to get it in the mail
late they would
sign the form because it was within
their scope we need to line this up like
other states have done to make this
practice efficient and in the best
interests of our patients in our Health
Care system so I'll conclude my
testimony I'm open to questions I think
these folks might be better at it than I
am but I could try okay thank you
senator
questions for Senator Apprentice
representative Nagel thank you for um
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question I just screwed up on that
with the last question I'm like
absolutely shocked that you can't do
this now yeah I married two nurse
practitioners my wife's an identical
twin and they're both nurse
practitioners
and I was totally under the
belief that they could do this now I'm
surprised they can't
they are signing for thank you thank you
for the question they are signing forms
within their own scope but this really
needs to be clarified and you know I
appreciate the question because it
reminds me of one thing that I didn't
say uh we have support from the New
Hampshire Medical Society no you do yes
we've we've spoken with them early on in
the stakeholder process and sorted this
out so we're in a good place there thank
you Dr Nagel you're welcome thank you
other questions representative
and I'm sure you can answer this but
thank you for taking my question thank
you for taking my question thank you Mr
chairman for taking my questions thank
you
I get excited about asking questions
so your form the form that the the nurse
practitioner signed for your daughter
if the camp
thinks it needs to be signed by a doctor
can they reject it no and they didn't
okay
it was within their scope of practice to
sign that form well I understood that
but I wondered about people they didn't
even ask a question and if they had I
would have pointed it out and I would
think may I sorry
I would have pointed it out but I'll I
also think that most parents put in that
position if they were asked that
question would make a phone call verify
and then go back to the camp I mean so
we could fix all this by by doing this
work and the state of Maine has done
this as well
thank you you're welcome representative
Weber
so to clarify what we're doing is
conforming the statute with what's
already happening in practice correct
and just cleaning it up thank you
representative thank you yes
other questions
so you know all the questions thank you
Senator you're welcome I'm going to step
out to another hearing but I'll
certainly stop back and see if there's
anything else I can do for you thank you
for your time
thank you
they also signed up to speak as Nancy
Wilson from the New Hampshire nurse
practitioner Association
I'll put your microphone on please
there you go there we go thank you thank
you Mr chairman for allowing uh this
opportunity to speak on behalf of Senate
bill 83. my name is Nancy Wilson
I have a master's in uh of Science and
nursing and practiced with Concord
family medicine for 10 years
I am also a representative of the New
Hampshire nurse practitioner Association
this Association
is also part of the American Association
of nurse practitioners
if you allow me I want to give you a
little background on this important
Association
we represent uh new uh armps and
midwives nurse midwives here in um
uh sorry our all advanced breakfast
nurse practitioners and uh
midwives here in New Hampshire
the purpose of the of the association
uh is a as a state Professional
Organization
uh that is to
enhance uh and explain and keep our
scope of practice
the mission is to empower nurse
practitioners and Champion their
practice
our vision is fortifying the role of
nurse practitioners as leaders in New
Hampshire Health Care
our values
integrity
honesty and transparency excellence
continuous Pursuit Of Education and
growth
leadership
and Innovation to Excel and stewardship
of the nurse New Hampshire nurse
practitioner Association
respect respect for
the diversity of opinion
as
and contribution
service commitment to serve nurse
practitioners in New Hampshire
a letter has been submitted
to the chairman and to your in this
committee
I would like to draw your attention
uh to one paragraph
excuse me
Senate Bill 83 does not expand the scope
of practice for arnps it will only allow
aarmps to sign paperwork that reflects
the care they have already provided
to authorize the nurse practitioner who
is already treating the patient to also
treat the paperwork
statues written before armps were
providing the level of care they provide
today have not been updated to include
recognition for ARP signatures on many
patient care documents
this disconnect between treating the
patient and signing the paperwork
contributes to costly unnecessary
interruptions in care and delays and I
can speak personally
I perform many Camp physicals in the
past and indeed uh
they needed that extra step of a
physician
looks like a tour of a physician's
signature which which delayed uh the the
form being submitted and sometimes
um unreasonable delays because sometimes
these forms uh as it happened were being
submitted at the last minute
uh I would like to elaborate on
um
some of the
forms that uh
might be
um included in the daily provision of
care it's possible that dozens of forms
will be needed to sign
to ensure fulfillment of orders
referrals or recognition of Care by
various entities some of these some of
the examples
are child vaccine and lead testing
exemptions
excuse me Pharmacy dispensing of
marijuana products
certifying disability for patients to
receive this disabled parking permits
and placards
disability certification for public
assistance and public servant retirement
benefits
hospital and non-hospital birth
certificates
examination specifically for wrestlers
and boxers athletic events
forms related to end-of-life care
workers compensation forms excusing a
potential jury member due to illness
I would
appreciate any questions at this point
questions
representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question a couple of us were
talking before we opened the hearing on
the bill of being surprised that nurse
practitioners couldn't do this because
I'm remembering that when my late
husband died at home as recent as far
back as the year 2000 the hospice nurse
who was not an advanced practice uh
practitioner
was able to certify and and to fill out
the death certificate then and so I was
really surprised when I when I saw this
but is that a specific exception because
of the hospice connection or is it
probably probably I'm not as familiar
with that but uh yes that's probably
under that thank you
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question so is the reason
that this is necessary is because all of
these forms
are in statute somehow are what I'm
sorry the forms themselves or in statute
is that the reason they couldn't just be
changed to align with the actual
practice we have to pass a law to
actually do this yeah
thank you
representative Palmer
so this may be I'm I'm looking for more
relief from having to sign stuff than
maybe is here
um I uh because all of the things that
you brought up seemed like a
perfectly Common Sense thing
um I work in a critical access hospital
as a hospitalist and so yesterday I was
working with a nurse practitioner I
worked with for years
um in the critical access hospital and
this isn't got to be a federal law I
still have to sign everything I know and
so that's a little frustrating we're not
going to solve that in New Hampshire the
other one though that's a little less
clear to me is
um whether this would cover things like
um durable medical equipment forms or um
or like Visiting Nurse referrals yeah I
I don't believe so because again I
believe federally mandated anything to
do with Medicare yeah
it's too bad yeah again we're we're
trying to
get that changed as well but yeah yeah
well good luck on that thank you I would
appreciate you
other questions
seeing no other questions
okay well thank you very much thank you
I have no one else signed up to testify
on Senate Bill 83 does anyone else wish
to testify
seeing no one else I'm going to close
the public hearing on Senate bill 83.
our next hearing is not scheduled until
1 pm
so we will be in recess until that time
thank you all
foreign
of the funding and is that from
insurance
companies
so the current pillars of the system
that exist today the lifeline call
center is that someone to talk to and
the mobile crisis response teams that's
somewhere to go those are funded through
um the through both Medicaid and state
funds and state general funds and they
what we're looking to do with the bill
is really it's an education and
recommendation opportunity so we're
looking to make sure that we find figure
out which mix of funding is best for New
Hampshire to make sure the services are
both robust and sustainable so it's
about building out the somewhere to go
third pillar of a crisis system that is
that National best practice model and
it's also about making sure the funding
is sustainable over time so some of this
is is currently funded yes is it funded
long-term and robustly enough to meet
the need of the state is the question so
we would be looking for that committee
to study those pieces with the
assistance of members from that 988
Coalition who have done some of the
research about what's working nationally
what other states are doing and so
that's the makeup and membership of that
committee would help to inform what New
Hampshire could do and what would be the
right fit for our state
follow-up follow-up
um I went before the oversight committee
probably two three days ago
and then much to my surprise this is
very much like what I was asking the
oversight committee to consider that
they have the authority to form
subcommittee uh work and there seemed to
be a positive response to my suggestions
some people were saying don't you have
enough to do already but
uh the uh so I'm very pleased with this
and I'm very pleased to see who the
sponsors are that but but I'm trying to
say where does this fit into what
already exists the legislature in recent
years has
been very positive in their response and
particularly in the development of the
10-year plan so do you have any thoughts
about how this
the legislation fits into the 10-year
mental health plan this is a direct
build out of recommendations within the
10-year mental health plan so making
sure that there is a centralized access
point when people are in crisis and that
there is community-based response in
that moment when people are most
vulnerable and so the the this is you
know baked in work right into the
10-year Mental Health Plan
um and the existing Services would also
be a part of the fiscal analysis to make
sure that that is the the pieces the
services that are in place today the
amazing strides that New Hampshire has
made would be maintained long term and
is robust enough to meet the need
thank you okay representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman thank you very
much for taking my question
um I have a lot of questions actually
but the first one is how does this how
does the existing doorways program
interface with this and how are you
contemplating rolling the two together
given the number of
um
um substance abuse issues that are
coexisting problems with with mental
health issues a great question thank you
so much so part of the 988 planning
Coalition does uh also include doorway
Representatives
um it we also have our state opioid
response director working very closely
on this work who oversees the doorway
program and we are looking at our the
New Hampshire rapid response in 988
actually being a crisis as defined by
the individual and so it does not take
it does not say that you can only call
for specific reasons it is an integrated
Behavioral Health response so you could
call this Lifeline with a substance use
disorder or people who use drugs people
with a mental health or co-occurring
illness it really would be just the
crisis as defined by the person so we're
building a more integrated system at
this time your current state is going to
be that that rapid response a 988 call
line have memorandums of understanding
in place with the doorways and can do
transfers to them or referrals to them
um when the person is de-escalated from
the crisis we wouldn't transfer a call
during a moment of Crisis but if we were
able to de-escalate the caller and they
were ready for a referral they work
directly with the doorway to get people
into substance use disorder treatment
today and future State our inner our
care in New Hampshire should continue to
integrate more and more
and follow up
they're not follow-ups I have to set
entirely separate questions so if you
want to answer if you want to recognize
somebody else that's fine but I do have
a couple more go ahead okay so my second
question is
um this Coalition already exists so why
do we need to put it in statute yeah
it's a great question so I think part of
this is about making sure that we
involve our legislature in the planning
and the work and
um and making sure that we come forward
with recommendations that may include
future legislation
and and one last one if I may and this
may not be your area of expertise but I
do note that this also includes
insurance coverage provisions
do you want to tell us a little bit
about that or do you want to leave that
to Senator Bradley who I see is now here
or sure Senator Bradley new Futures and
the insurance department have already
collaborated closely on that portion of
the bill so they really would be the
best folks to answer any questions in
that area okay thank you very much
uh representative Nagel uh
representative Shapiro I'm sorry thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
the question
um
I certainly am a big supporter of mobile
crisis teams um and that they're now at
least attempting to be comprehensive
throughout the state
um one
one concern I've heard locally
um from consumers at our local Mental
Health Center is that
through their Emergency Services prior
to there being a mobile crisis team when
they called they were likely to speak to
someone
an answering service first but quickly
someone who was part of the local Mental
Health Center and
um maybe knew them or at the very least
knew the people who worked with them and
knew the resources in the community and
now when they call they get somebody
unless it's changed recently they get
somebody out of state who does not know
anything about the local
resources the local services and
certainly not that person's particular
services so that was disconcerting to at
least a few people who mentioned this to
me and I wonder if there's any
thoughts I know this is not directly
related to this bill but if there are
any thoughts to making the phone
response
kind of closer to the um
consumers who are actually reaching out
for help yeah thank you so much for your
question we are very dedicated to
figuring out quality improvement around
the system every day it's such a new
system in New Hampshire the
recommendation in the tenure Mental
Health Plan the 10-year Mental Health
Plan was a broad stakeholder I did a lot
of work of understanding deeply what are
the needs in New Hampshire and the
recommendation included a centralized
access point in order to make sure that
there was Equitable Services across the
state because as you know what we have
is some areas that are resource dense
and others that are very resource scarce
so making sure that no matter where
you're located no matter your age and no
matter why you're calling you can
receive the same kind of care right and
so that's the purpose of that
centralized access point the the mobile
crisis response teams are still
connected to your Community Mental
Health Centers I understand that it's a
very challenging change whenever we go
through a system transformation we have
pain
right I think what how I best understand
what you're describing is that we used
to call our local police department and
when we called 9-1-1 now we can't even
remember what our local police
department's phone numbers are it's not
something we memorize right and so this
is the idea of that centralized access
point in some ways is similar I worry
about likening it directly to 9-1-1
because in 9-1-1 you always get an
in-person response and it's pretty quick
in Behavioral Health that's not always
true at this time right it's not always
really fast we're building something new
and everyone doesn't need an in-person
response but if you think about it from
the phone number perspective we're
trying to simplify that phone number so
it's easier to use we're trying to
centralize it so that we can have
Equitable Services across the state and
it's a work in progress and the
department is doing quality improvement
process has entered into a contract
monitoring all of these services that
also includes focus groups it includes
surveys for consumers and any feedback
is always welcome
I thank you for that response and I
think um
change is difficult and
whenever we consider any bill there's
something gained and something lost and
you have to go with the most benefit and
I appreciate that I guess I just hope
that you'll take this concern back to
people who are monitoring
um Quality and what what the real needs
are absolutely it is something that
we're already considering today thank
you
other questions
uh yes sir representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question
on page
two line five
which is a tremendous statement
removing
prior authorization requirements does it
apply to all payers or only some payers
into all authorizations that require
private authorization including
admission to a hospital can you sort of
elaborate on that as far as what the
extent of that means I do think that
question is better answered by Senator
Bradley new futures or the insurance
department thank you thank you
other questions
so you know other questions thank you
thank you
at this time I would welcome Senator
Bradley to come forward and uh testify
and he remembered his pink card that
hasn't happened every time today
Senator um
um Kate lippman had also signed up and
she said she was representing you I
assume that's no longer yeah no other
it's fine
um but thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Jeff Bradley uh
from Senate District 3 apologized I was
testifying on a bill across the hall
so I was approached to file this bill by
new Futures who are here today to
testify in support of it
um it's actually a fairly simple bill
let me just try to go through
um you know some of the parameters of
the bill
as the purpose statement outlines in
2020 the National Suicide Hotline
designation Act was signed into law
currently right now there are two
vendors I'm using primarily federal
funds to operate this
suicide line 988 that's run by the
substance abuse of Mental Health
Services Administration
um
obviously suicide mental health
substance misuse huge problems around
the country huge problems in our state
so having a 988 line
is very important I think for every
person in the state of New Hampshire so
the purpose of
the commission that's established just
to look at a sustainable way to fund it
as that Federal funding
may not always be available and so that
is the large purpose of the
um
commission that's created in this bill
there's also a new definition
on page two of what a Behavioral Health
crisis program is that is in line with
this Federal
legislation the purpose statement
outlines some of the pillars of what a
um crisis
intervention and stabilization should
look like and that's Roman 3 on page two
line seven through
um 20.
obviously we want to create that as much
as possible here in New Hampshire so a
broad array of Public Health experts
in the commission outlined on page three
and then there was a question from
representative Merchant about section
four you referred to you know the
purpose statement in it but it this
ensures that prior authorizations are
treated the same for mental health as
they are under current law for substance
abuse I mean that just makes all the
sense in the world that's section four
um I just looked up the bill because I
had to refresh my memory there was no
controversy about this bill as I recall
in the Senate it passed out of the
um Senate Health and Human Services
committee on the consent calendar went
to finance and passed on a Voice vote so
with that I'm happy to answer any
questions
for Senator Bradley
representative Weber
chairman thank you for taking my
question
so is the purpose of the language on
page four lines 10 uh and and following
is the purpose of that to ensure that
there is uh insurance coverage for these
services or is the purpose of that
something slightly different now the
purpose of it is to ensure that the same
treatment for prior authorizations under
insurance law that currently exists for
substance misuse which is pretty
expedited prior authorization also
applies for mental health crises
and may I have a follow-up
that brings us back to the piece
highlighted I think by representative
Merchant uh
because there's a statement about on
page two line four about removing prior
authorization requirements therefore
making Health Care treatment accessible
without delay and that's the whole point
so the prior authorization requirements
and their
um
I think there are other people that can
answer specifically what they are and
you probably remember because I believe
you were on the Commission in 2015 or 16
that representative hinch and I
um chaired where we wrote much of the
legislation and included expedited prior
authorizations no I missed that one but
oh well okay
um sorry about that I thought you were
but in any case we wanted to make sure
that people didn't get hung up in the
middle of a substance abuse crisis with
a prior authorization and so we
fixed it if you will we want to make
sure that the same treatment for mental
health crises
is part of the New Hampshire law thank
you very much that helps a lot yeah
representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
I don't know what's the purp what's the
proper title now I think as Mr President
uh
Congress job works the best
call me anything you want just don't
call me a Yankee fan
today is oh we have some Yankee fans
here
[Laughter]
today it's all positive well I say that
because tomorrow's opening day you know
the uh I went before the oversight
committee on health and
Human Services up two or three days ago
to ask that they form a committee that
feels very much like what this is doing
that was met with
a positive response I think and that
they were willing to use the
structure that's already there and has
been used in the past so that part of
the legislation
uh I think is super and and as far as
I'm concerned we can go ahead and start
doing this immediately that's one of the
advantages of the
um that committee is that they don't
have to wait till all of the process
goes on
I am
extremely
excited to see this legislation and
and support it in in general
um the the part that confused me a bit
was that there's no appropriation
in this legislation
and so again let me just stress what the
purpose the primary purpose of the
commission is
um the 988 line right now is funded
um
primarily by federal funds
through two organizations Beacon access
point and head rest Beacon is funded
with
um eight percent federal funds and
actually 92 percent
federal funds headrest is funded 18
federal funds and 82 percent federal
funds but my understanding is these were
um
funds that uh came from arpa now I could
be wrong on that but in any case we need
a
permanent funding mechanism to ensure
the continuation of the 988
suicide line and that's what the primary
purpose of the commission is
thank you very much
in my backing thank you
other questions
representative Weber
how long if you know is the federal
funding going to hold up for I what kind
of time frame are we under that I don't
know and I suspect the folks from new
Futures can answer that
I'm seeing heads nodding behind you so
thank you
other questions
seeing none thank you Senator chair
appreciate it
also signed up to speak appropriately
enough is uh Mr savigne from new futures
hello
please put your microphone on sorry
there you go thank you for having me I'm
Emma savini I'm the children's
Behavioral Health policy coordinator at
new Futures and as Senator Bradley um
mentioned we approached him
um about this bill
um after working with that Coalition
that the department mentioned
um on the 988 planning and
implementation we felt that this was the
appropriate next step to start the
legislative process into finding a
sustainable funding source for these
programs
um so as everyone has mentioned the bill
just creates a study commission to look
at the best possible funding stream for
sustainable funding for these programs
in New Hampshire as was mentioned every
state is grappling with this and every
state is kind of looking at different
models but we want one that fits New
Hampshire
um secondly that pre-authorization
section it removes the pre-authorization
requirement for Behavioral Health crisis
emergencies and that does include
substance use emergencies as well it
brings us in line both with uh creating
parity between substance use disorder
and mental health crises and then also
you know physical ailments and mental
health crises
um I believe the last question was when
the federal funding runs out just after
just a quick look it looks like the 988
there are two call centers those funding
streams are approved it looks like
annually in the governor's uh through
governor and Council and they have
contracts that run through June of 2023
so this year and then they have the
option to be renewed and they are a mix
of federal and general funds for each
um
call center and so those federal funds
may be renewed but we will need a
sustainable funding eventually those
those funds will be gone
um I'm happy to take any other questions
or
um
okay representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um with the removal of pre-authorization
is it removal of it or Expediting it
it's the removal of it so um thank you
thank you question so so my the second
part of my question you can answer it
all is um does this include
Services provided in an emergency room
or out in the community or does it also
include Hospital admissions
it's a great question
so the Emergency Services definition
covers
um
any health care services that are
provided to an enrollee
um in a or insured or subscriber in a
licensed Hospital facility so it would
be
um you know going to the emergency room
for a crisis
or showing up to um eventually if this
is the form that pillar takes an
emergency crisis facility on one of
those as well
I believe
so I have two follow-up questions really
one is
um so does it also exclude uh
authorization for an admission if that
hospital if that person is to be
admitted to a hospital
um
thank you for your question I believe it
would cover if that admission is part of
the emergency services that are needed
to handle that emergency crisis
um yes but if it is an admission after
the emergency crisis has resolved that
would be a separate thing that may may
require pre-authorization
um so one thing I'm unsure a little
unsure of is that since
one of the things that's often talked
about when as one of the benefits of
mobile crisis teams is that potentially
can keep people out of emergency rooms
and provide services in homes and
schools in the community
so why aren't we also
um
excluding pre-authorizations for
services that happen elsewhere otherwise
we're kind of incentivizing people
to give these services in emergency
rooms
thank you for your question
um it's my understanding that with the
mobile crisis Services those are handled
a little bit differently and I'm not
sure the intricacies of the insurance
coverage for those pieces so that may be
better answered by the insurance
department
thank you thank you
other questions uh representative Weber
thank you this is just if you know you
may not have any knowledge of this but I
wound up sitting on finance yesterday so
I'm thinking about these things do you
have any idea if the governor has
included any funds or if the department
included any funds for the gap between
say June of 2023 going forward for these
Services because it seems to me that
what we're planning for here is
long-term
funding sources but we need to get from
here to long term if if the current
Source comes to an end on the 23rd on
the end of in the end of June
thank you for your question it's my
understanding that those contracts have
the option to be extended already built
into them
um but I can double check on that
information and get it back to you and
if I may for follow-up the the issue is
not whether the contracts may be renewed
but whether there will be the funds to
pay for them if they are renewed so
that's that's my specific question I
understand now if you can find if you
can find that out that would be really
helpful thank you
representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman
it
the um
would you believe that I just went
before the oversight committee on Health
and Human Services
with a suggestion that is very similar
to this uh
recommendation
that we form a committee to essentially
look into the 10-year plan which covers
all of the details would you believe
that we can work much faster under the
oversight committee than the whole
procedure we have to go through to form
committees so that we could form that
committee and it has had a positive
response so far
that would you believe that that part of
the legislation
could be initiated almost immediately
um I would believe that you're you're um
I could say new future very likely would
be on that committee
that that would be excellent and um I'd
be happy to look into that as well thank
you for bringing that to my attention
all right thank you other questions
saying no other questions thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak is Holly Stevens
from Nami New Hampshire
good afternoon chairman members of the
committee my name is Holly Stevens I'm
the director of public policy for Nami
New Hampshire
Nami is a Grassroots non-profit
organization
[Music]
whose mission is to improve the lives of
all impacted by mental illness and
suicide through support education and
advocacy and on behalf of Nami New
Hampshire I'm here today in support of
Senate bill 85. before I go into a
little bit of my testimony and why we're
here today just heard from the
Department that the funding goes through
2025.
you're welcome
um
so I just wanted to go through some of
the statistic statistics that you
haven't heard
um for this bill yet today which is that
suicide is the second leading cause of
death for individuals 10 to 34 and this
is in the state of New Hampshire this is
not nationally this is these are State
of New Hampshire stats
um the third leading cause of death for
individuals 35 to 44 and the fourth
leading cause of death for individuals
45 to 54. last year in our state we lost
279 lives to suicide and we know that 53
000 of our fellow Granite Staters
contemplated suicide
one in five adults in the U.S experience
mental illness each year and that's 221
000 of the the residents of New
Hampshire which is a significant amount
have they have mental health conditions
and we know that one in six U.S youth
age 16 excuse me 6 to 17 experience of
mental health disorder each year and we
know that in the state of New Hampshire
there are 15 000 youngsters that are
grappling with depression right now
um as you've heard Senate Bill 85 sets
up a framework of what the crisis system
should look like in our state based on
what has come down from samhsa with the
three pillars I won't get into those
and you've also heard some about the
coverage
um of getting rid of the prior
authorizations and that's something
that's extremely important for parity
because what it does is it puts
physical
emergency services that you'd receive in
an ER on par with
Mental Health Services and there is a if
you look at
page four lines 21-23 it does say under
this chapter it says without the
requirement of being provided in a
licensed hospital emergency facility if
such services are provided under the
program established under RSA 167 colon
3 Dash L3 that is that reference to RSA
167 is the statute that the mobile
crisis programs were developed under
so so long as the services are provided
by one of our mobile crisis teams they
are covered regardless of whether it's
in somebody's home or whether it's in an
emergency room and I think that's really
important to to consider because this
does keep people out of the ERS
um and I know that representative McKay
has mentioned a few times that setting
up the committee through the oversight
HHS oversight and I just
I know that with the commission if you
read through all of the members of it
there are people from insurance
because we you know may be looking at a
way for the insurers to become involved
in this
um and and do so on a voluntary basis
we've got folks from the 911 system that
are also involved in this so that we can
maybe take a look at how that gets
funded and whether we should be looking
at those options so I think
um that you know perhaps those two could
be work in concert together I also you
know looking at the whole 10-year mental
health plan is a huge chunk where we
know that this funding is ending in a
couple of years making sure that we have
a plan for sustainable funding
when that money Runs Out is extremely
important so with that I will end and
take any questions
thank you questions uh representative
Weber
and I'm thinking about the issue of what
we can do Under the Health and Human
Services oversight and and what we can
do in a commission and bearing in mind
the fact that we have a lot of
commissions but also
um
would it would I be correct in thinking
that the difference between this and the
oversight commission is there's actually
a line in here on page two
at the bottom of the page on lines 34
and 35 which attach this Commission
administratively to the Department of
Health and Human Services so there there
might be some support there that is not
available to
uh any committee or commission that's
simply a a subdivision of something
created by the legislature
if you know if that's outside your area
of expertise that's fine my area of the
expertise but I do know the Department's
still here so they might be able to pop
up and answer that question for you okay
I hope they will thank you
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question
in regards to
treatment of Mental Health
what's not addressed here maybe it
doesn't have to be
my concern is we don't want to overlook
it
can you speak to Telehealth and the use
of Telehealth versus it being done
physically because a lot of times
if I understand it correctly getting
somebody to a provider is critical and
sometimes it's hard to find providers
that readily available yet we could have
a pool of providers that could do things
through Telehealth that they couldn't do
physically
crisis system itself which is the phone
calls that folks receive for support and
the mobile crisis teams that go to where
the people are
and it's when they need them whether
that's three in the morning whether
that's on the weekend so I think the
issue with not having providers
available to go to somebody
um isn't as prevalent in this model
because the whole crisis system is built
on the mobile crisis team being able to
go out and respond where they're needed
in the community
other questions
seeing none okay thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is and I applied
my best for the last name Alex fedrebel
New Hampshire insurance department
how did I do
pretty good okay with the name I mean
yes
um thank you Mr chairman my name is Alex
valve I'm uh an examiner from the
insurance department and uh my part of
my responsibility is cover Healthcare
issues with the legislature
and
um I wanted to make myself available
because the insurance department was
raised in the
discussion so far but let me just take a
minute to try to answer some of the
questions that have come up or reinforce
the answers that have already been given
the language at the end of the bill
deals with
the statute that governs coverage for
emergency Health Care Services
with respect to commercial insurance
carriers and what is going on here is
we're incorporating into that definition
of Emergency Services
community-based Mental Health crisis
intervention services and the effect of
that is first of all to eliminate any
prior authorization because it has
already been a part of the law governing
Emergency Services is that there's no
such thing as prior authorization for
emergency care so that's how that part
of it works by bringing community-based
Mental Health Services into the
definition of Emergency Services you
eliminate the this issue of prior
authorization
and then secondly there were some
questions about maintaining the
community nature of these crisis
intervention services and that was an
issue
um with the prior definition of
Emergency Services because it referred
to a hospital-based services so we added
additional language and I helped myself
with this amendment here
um
that made it clear that even though the
services are offered in the community
they can still qualify as Emergency
Services Under this insurance law
so long as they're sponsored by this
program that's referenced that the Holly
Stevens reference for you on line 23 of
page four
so that's how it works and that's why
this language is here and I'd be happy
to answer any other questions for you
thank you any questions
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman I'm not sure since
you said that any any service I think
you said
um correct me if I'm wrong any service
that's
um
that falls under Emergency Services
already excludes
um prior auth authorizations yeah so is
this bill saying that they
that it's going to exclude prior
authorizations is it real is it
redundant in some way I guess it's like
no I think it's the most efficient way
to exclude prior authorization
requirements for these crisis
intervention services is to include them
in the definition of Emergency Services
follow one more question
um
I don't mean to speed ahead and do the
work of the commission but
or these kinds of um
you know answering services that take
initial calls
um are those ever reimbursable Services
Under Telehealth and might that will be
a way to fund programs like this
um
I only speak to commercial health
insurance and I don't believe that
original
answering service is is billed as a part
of Emergency Services because big
follow-up because I think they're
staffed by
at least I believe their staff by
clinical
um
providers but in any case that doesn't
really apply to the bill so uh
um
thank you very much
other questions
saying no other questions okay thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak is Nicole
chief
Exeter
thank you Mr chairman thank you very
much to communion members my name is
Nicole schief I'm a resident of Exeter
New Hampshire obviously I have a 14 year
old daughter
and she became her mental health Journey
when she was six we found out when she
was nine that she was diagnosed with
Lyme disease and it completely changed
her personality from six to nine to the
point where she had extreme anxiety she
would have Tantrums we would have to
pull over in the car and let her out
when she was nine
we got to the point where we had to
call police and EMTs and bring her for
her first hospitalization when she was
nine years old
she was there
for three days and I was there with her
She was transferred to New Hampshire
State Hospital
and over the course of the next two
months she was discharged and then
placed back into crisis
um
two more times so it was 63 days total
and she spent about 35 of those days
either in the emergency room
or in New Hampshire hospital
two years ago she's had two more
hospitalizations over in Hampstead
Hospital
and recently when she was 11.
um she was started struggling from
severe PTSD from her experiences at
inpatient hospitals and emergency rooms
um
to the point where thinking about taking
her to the emergency room was a trauma
response
during the pandemic as we know when she
was 11 we were in the emergency room for
three weeks
I was living with her for three weeks in
the emergency room
um
and
she had no access to a shower she had no
interaction with anyone but me
and I watched while she was physically
and chemically sedated at age 11.
after that placement we placed her into
a voluntary residential
because the need was just
um
was too much
um I actually quit my job
before
we placed her residential because she
needed so much services
that we weren't able to access
um
she came out of residential after a year
a completely different person
she was I'd say 80 back to who she is
who she was
except for the trauma piece that was
unaddressed
about
four weeks ago
um
well let me back up a moment but
probably in November she started having
um
regressing with trauma and I had to call
988 twice over the past four months
and if I can speak to what
representative Shapiro said
um
you get a
a person who might be in a different
state
um to speak to
and unfortunately I had to drive her to
our community mental health agency and
sit in the parking lot and wait for
about two hours to find out that no one
was coming from mobile crisis because
there was no availability of anybody
so I was able to contact her therapist
and drive her down for uh another
appointment
another thing I'd like to comment as is
when she began this journey
I took her off my private insurance
I could not access what she needed she
needed home supports and the only way I
could do that through our community
mental health department is on Medicaid
so I took her off of my insurance and
put her on Medicaid
when I quit my job we lost our insurance
so all of us now are on Medicaid
so she is back because of her trauma and
some of the facilities in on in New
Hampshire
um we placed her directly in a
community-based acute treatment program
in Massachusetts
this past time from a week in the
emergency room
directly there
the funding source is through the Bureau
of children's and Behavioral Health that
I had to call personally and request
them to pay for that placement
just over
right now we're currently she's she's in
the cbat program and we are working on
finding her an intensive trauma
treatment placement that will most
likely be out of state
um but over the six years that we've
been working with this
um I have researched every organization
and Department I have made phone calls
I've speak into I've spoken to some of
the Senators here
to get access for mental health for her
and I've discovered that a lot of the
providers in the area do not take the
insurance
either my private or now Medicaid
because of the low reimbursement rates
I've discovered that we've had a lot of
Staff turn over in a lot of our
therapies and even in our community
mental health providers I'd say once a
year they change because of decreased
staff pay
and I've had to become her case manager
her social worker
her teacher her therapist and I've never
been able to just be her mom
I've had to work so hard to get her what
she needs
and I believe in the mobile crisis unit
and I'm I'm asking for this committee to
to push through SB 85 I think New
Hampshire is beginning their journey in
mental health
and I think making sure there's more
crisis mobile crisis units in the state
will increase the ability to get to
people faster to talk to people faster
and I know just recently we've had to
call the police and the EMTs
to come in and assist us when she has
been suicidal
and I think that there are limited
options right now for the community
supports and especially the Intensive
supports that children like my daughter
need
um
it's almost over and above what the
community-based mental health can
provide
so just focusing on the preventive
measure and really looking at how to
fund and keep
um
988 going and Crisis Support going in
the state of New Hampshire
thank you
questions from committee members yes
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thank you very much for your
presentation I really appreciate that um
this may be a hard question to ask and
if you don't want to answer it it's fine
that's fine you said something that
really touched something in me you said
um PTSD from experiences and
places that were designed to help her
can you expand on that
and if you can't don't worry about it
during one of her three
little somehow she was sexually
assaulted
and there's um
a current investigation that's going on
but we're not sure but that
that brought her
to where she is now really sorry I'm
sorry I brought that up but so now
and because
more things happened at Hampstead
we can't place her anywhere in New
Hampshire because I don't feel like
she's safe
um
so we keep her home
and we do everything we can to make our
home
as safe as possible with
locking up Sharps cameras in every
single room interior door locks
um
we are her biggest advocate
and
lime brought us here and then her
experience has brought us to where we
are now
um so
I guess it is
so important to fund mental health
because you never know
who or when or where
and I'm a pediatric OT
and
you know I
did whatever I could
but it's just over my
experience now
thank you for your question
that's okay
other questions
so you know other questions thank you
very much thank you
no one else has signed up to testify
does anyone else want to testify on
Senate bill 85.
seeing no one I will close the public
hearing on Senate bill 85. that is the
last piece of legislation we had a
notice for hearing today
so we are adjourned for the day we will
be reconvening next Tuesday at 9 30 A.M
thank you
Lucy you're not going to have that that
report ready for today but